Dre Tremblay est avec nous.
Bonsoir Dre Tremblay.
- Bonsoir M. Roy.
- Alors, on voit depuis
plusieurs jours en Europe,
dans les pays que j'ai nommés,
il y a vraiment... la courbe est
impressionnante vers le haut.
Est-ce que vous craignez,
parce que les vagues ont
toujours commencé en Europe
et sont arrivées ici, est-ce que
vous craignez que ça arriveou i,
compte tenu de notre taux
de vaccination?
- Bien, je crois qu'il faut
faire attention parce qu'à date,
jusqu'à présent, ce qui s'est
passé en Europe a toujours
prédit ce que nous, on a subi
es semaines après, parfois
c'est un mois de décalage.
C'est certain qu'il y a
une différence et la différence,
elle est majeure, en terme
de taux de vaccination,
où on voit que les pays,
même en Europe, qui ont un taux
de vaccination plus élevé,
voient moins... une augmentation
moins importante du nombre de
cas, mais ils voient quand même
une augmentation du nombre de
cas. Alors, c'est vraiment relié
à la vaccinatnt
des épidémies de non-vaccinés,
essentiellement. Et on sait
qu'une certaine proportion
des gens vaccinés peuvent avoir
la maladie, mais dans
la majorité des cas, ils ne font
pas de maladie grave. Donc, oui,
il faut suivre ça de près ici
parce que ça risque d'arriver
que laion
communautaire se remette
à augmenter, d'autant plus
qu'on relâche certaines mesures
artir d'auartir d'auartir d'aua.
- Bon, on rappelle aux gens que
les hospitalisations en Ontario,
au Québec, restent stables.
Donc ça, c'est la bonne nouvelle
pour l'instant. Est-ce que...
vous dites que c'est une
épidémie de non-vaccinés,
une pandémie de non-vaccinés,
est-ce qu'on est sûrs
et certains, avec étude
à l'appui que les vaccinés
transmettent moins la maladie
que les non-vaccinés?
- On sait que les vaccinés
peuvent transmettre la maladie.
Certaines études ont démontré
que peu importe la charge
virale... la charge virale peut
e similaire similaire similairee
non vaccinée que chez
une personne vaccinée.
Pour la simple raison que
quand on attrape la maladie,
si on est asymptomatique,
si elle ne descend pas dan
les voies respiratoires,
bien au niveau du nez,
ce n'est pas là que
les anticorps combattent.
Donc, on peut avoir pas mal
de virus dans les voies
respiratoires supérieures
puis la transmettre aux autres.
Donc, on peut dire que
les vaccins, je regardaisles ch,
vont protéger de l'infection
symptomatique et sévère encore
dans des pourcentage trèsélevés.
85 à 90 %. Mais la transmission
on est plus autour de l'ordre
de 80 % ou 75 %. Donc, il y a
peut-être une vingtaine de
pour-cent de gens qui peuvent
l'attraper même s'ils sont
vaccinés.
- Donc, les vaccinés,
quand même, répandent moins
la maladie que les non-vaccinéÇr
comme fait.
- Bien en fait, c'est qu'il y a
moins de personnes vaccinéesquie
au départ. Donc en soi,
c'est ça qui est le fait.
Donc, s'ils ne l'attrapent pas,
ils ne vont pas la transmettre.
Mais s'ils l'attrape,
smettre aussi
efficacement qu'une personne pas
vaccinée. Alors, je pense que
c'est ça la nuance qu'il faut
même si on est
asymptomatique, on peut
la transmettre. La preuve :
les petits enfants sont
cteurs impcteurs impcteurs impce
la maladie. Donc, ils ne sont
pas symptomatiques, ils n'ont
pas de maladie sévère,ls transm,
ils transmettent beaucoup.
- OK, mais vous venez dire,
avant, vous dites : quelqu'unt s
la maladie, donc il ne peut pas
la transmettre. Mais quelqu'un
qui est vacciné, peut êtreen co,
vivre avec sans problème
et ne pas être malade?
- Oui, je me suis probablement
mal exprimée. Les gens qui sont
vaccinés vont être protégés
contre la maladie sévère,
le décès, l'hospitalisation dûe
à la COVID...
- Voilà.
- ... à un ordre d'à peu près
90 %. Mais à peu près...
Ils sont protégés contre
la maladie elle-même.
L'infection, à peu près de
l'ordre de 70 à 80 %. Donc,
parmi les vaccinés, il y a
peut-être 20
qui peuvent attraper le virus,
mais ne pas devenir malades,
rester à symptomatiques.
Et ces gens-là peuvent
transmettre la maladie.
- OK, donc, toutes ces raisons-
là, vous, continuent à militer,
selon vous, pour qu'on pousse
la vaccination encore.
Que l'on encourage les gens
à se faire vacciner?
Qu'on n'arrête pas de
se faire vacciner?
- Absolument. Parce qu'on voit
que c'est ce qui va faire
la grande différence entre
le fait : est-ce qu'on va avoir
une cinquième vague comme
en Europe ou non
une bonne longueur d'avance
sur plusieurs pays d'Europe,
mais on a encore une proportion
de la population
qui est importante. On parle
de millions de personnes.
Donc, toutes ces personnes-là
peuven
et être à risque d'engorger
le système de santé. Donc, on a
tous hâte que l'autorisation
pour le vaccinése vaccinése vacs
arrive bientôt. Et c'est
important de continuer
à soutenir les efforts pour que
se
fasse vacciner et ne perde pas
son immunité. Donc, la troisième
dose va devenir très importante.
coup
de nous avoir parlé.
On va surveiller cette cinquième
vague européenne, est-ce qu'elle
dans quelle
mesure ici. Merci beaucoup
de nous avons parlé. Au revoir.
- Ça me fait